[Music]
so yes I'm going to talk about Markov
chain approximation to identify
financial fraud so a quick question
before starting is there anyone here
that knows the Markov chain
approximation what it is and worked with
it maybe maybe yeah okay
well for the rest don't worry you will
learn about it during the course of this
talk but you use Markov chain in
different areas and I came across this
nice tweet which says Markov chains are
used widely in the in industry and what
I want here to point is this last
sentence that they are actually used to
generate the scripts for the final
season of Game of Thrones right and so
but don't worry I'm not going to spoil
the final episode here joking aside now
let's get serious I'm going to talk
about finest financial fraud the
introduction is here the outline of the
talk there will be an introduction about
financial fraud artificial intelligence
to fight financial fraud and one of the
the methods
it's anomaly detection with Markov
chains which I'm going to introduce and
talk about it here an introduction to
what it is sequential data and more like
technical how do you do some encoding
strategy and don't get worried it's also
a demo notebook which will show you how
to build the mark of features from
scratch and at the end conclusions and
prospects okay I'm not going to say what
is machine learning you probably know
and if not you heard a lot of talks
during the the workshop but what I want
to say is that a is widely used in
different areas and of course also in
financial sector very used by machine
learning for trading strategies for
credit risk assignment and for
protection
AI has showed to be a successful tool
for for battling to battle a financial
fraud
when you talk about financial fraud
there are different types of financial
fraud and when I was preparing this talk
I went like okay what about I go and
make a nice summary of how many
financial frauds there are like how do
we group them and so on there was a long
list so I said okay I'm going to I'm
going to share here or the commonly
known starting with transactional throat
I think you already know or you can
guess what is transactional fraud I'd
like to show you a story here one day a
friend of mine came to me and said hey
free and I just get a call from the bank
someone duplicated my card in Indonesia
I was like Indonesia and I said yes I
was few months ago in Indonesia and
someone tried to actually use it this
this morning and I'm like really yes but
as I already had used it last night at
at one of the supermarkets here that was
kind of a suspicion you know activity
that how you can be on the in the time
difference of 3-4 hours in two different
places like Netherlands and Indonesia
right so this is an example then we have
loan fraud I'm going to talk about this
and give you an example later so the
basic idea is to apply for a loan you
get it and then you're actually not
going to pay it back you take the money
and disappear also the CX off-road it's
known I wanted to share a story so I
found this story in the in the news and
it's like when you get mail you are in
charge of the transactions and you get
mail and calls by your CEO saying make
this transfer urgently and this kind of
stuff but you can also google this link
and find more out stories about this
kind of fraud okay
of course we are fighting fraud we want
to suppress fraud and there are advanced
methods that are developed to deal with
this matter so we want to identify
financial fraud we want to identify the
patterns of course separate them
distinguish them from legitimate
clients and also to completely suppress
fraud now you might say ok so we are
advancing and why are we talking about
it why we haven't completely suppressed
fraud
well there are some challenges of course
and one of the challenges it's the
imbalance that I said so the number of
legitimate clients compared to to Freud
clients it's very imbalance we have very
low fraud cases which is very good right
but makes our life difficult and the one
who our data scientists in audience will
actually really understand what it means
to have imbalance datasets another
challenge is the concept drift fraud is
evolving actually constantly with time
seems that this fraudsters are
constantly adapting their model to get
around the the current system of fraud
detection and somehow they managed to do
so last but not least and also important
we normally do not have a target I
mentioned before the example with with
my friend story and like that you would
say which is the target we don't have a
label how did you know that this is
actually a fraud how would you label and
this is an easy example let's say that
it happened in two different country
with the time difference and other
things like that but there are other
things that you cannot actually you
don't have them labeled on your data set
despite the challenges there are also
new opportunities and one of the things
that we are going to talk today it's
also the web collected data and how the
client is actually interacting with with
the web to be more precise you heard
about loans maybe you thought of getting
one or you got one when you were a
student if not you probably know what
alone is so usually if you have
something online like a loan calculator
you have the possibility to explore how
much you can get them for how long you
can pay it back as an example here I
have generated this ID
a slider where you can actually put a
different amount and for how long you
would like to pay it back and I created
this last night just for the purpose of
this presentation so when I will say
this interest rate there just don't take
them seriously they are calculated by me
being very tired at night this is
nothing related with the real interest
how they are currently in the market so
let's go on the topic here you have an
amount south I want to ask 2000 euro and
I want to pay back for one year then I
was like I know the interest rate it's
two point forty two maybe I can explore
another opportunity and say like I want
more I want 7000 euros and paid back in
one year and then I see there okay
interest rate 1.71 okay what about seven
thousand is too much I get five thousand
and this in the plot you showed also
there you see a sequential data and this
is an example of sequential data but
people are different and every
individual has the right to explore the
possibilities and someone from here can
go and say like you know I don't want
that much I want because I have a bigger
problem I want fifty thousand then I
want to pay it back in five years and I
go and fill up those things I get some
results then I say what about I try to
get a bigger amount sixty thousand paid
back in a longer term and I keep on
trying this kind of things to see if
this actually fits my needs I have
created this way another sequential data
and this is something that it's just a
small part of the many sequential
interactions you could capture from the
web interaction just and this is just an
example and what we actually have it's
much more complicated than this and in a
bigger picture than what I showed here
so I said that different individuals
have different needs that means that
this ranges when for example the amount
of money we are requiring change
from one person to another making also
the range of this amounts different how
this change in direction can help us
make some study because sometimes you go
ask more sometimes you ask less
sometimes you change another feature
sometimes you try a new a new feature
then you'd like to make some some
meanings
you'd like to make some encoding which
it's actually going to capture this
changes you are trying and there are
different ways of course to do that and
one of the ways I have tried here it's
the encoding strategy which says if at
this point you go and fill up everything
and then in the next point what you
require it's something larger that what
you have previously required then I am
going to encode this as a plus one
because it goes up compared to the
previous one in case it didn't change
its zero and in case you try something
smaller than the in the previous step
it's minus one and this is just like a
technicality but very important for the
the study we are performing here to give
an example I am the person number one
someone here's the person number two I
go through in some numbers X Y Z then
everything in the first moment is filled
in it's change is new information so I
have 1 1 1 in the second trial I try
something different I change only X 1
which is larger and the remaining it's
unchanged this is why you have 1 0 0 and
so on so I think you can get the logic
out of it and then you also want to have
a different a unique value for all of
these changes ok in our modeling
strategy it's essential to combine
several well understood features and put
them into a complex model and these
features have the aim to explore the
data as much as possible we saw that
using web collected data we can kind of
have an encoding strategy to capture
this
Changez and we would like to obtain some
information based on these changes like
how they are actually going up and down
and how is they are there in a sequence
in the case of the of the loan
calculator or also in general for for
financial fraud the fraudulent class
shows a different pattern from the
legitimate clients and then it's the
moment to ask can we actually use this
kind of data to identify anomalies the
answer is yes one of the methods here
it's anomaly detection by matching
probabilities the idea is that you model
the non-fraudulent population and then
measure how likely is that a new
observation belongs to the normal
population of course you have to make
some assumption and the main assumption
is that the fraudulent behavior is the
is different from not in fraudulent
behavior
and that the most legitimate application
follow a similar path and fraudulent
application follow a different more
creative or anomaly so it's a path then
in case this assumption are true we can
separate the two classes we can separate
the fraud from the non fraud class okay
don't don't get scared
there's some math here but it's fine I
will just explain you what what it is
so one thing you have to remember the
Markov chain approximation the first and
the second formula all it is saying that
the future depends on the presence so
what I'm going to take next which step
I'm going to take next and in which
direction depends on my present state
right now and the two formulas basically
are just telling us us and for the one
who love math and like more formulas
this is just a way to calculate the
probabilities so how do you actually get
these probabilities
even here you are going here or you are
here or you're going here something like
that for example which is the
probability that I do not like chocolate
zero like if I put it this way it's zero
but it's more to say if you have like
for the one who are more for for
familiar with with the text processing
for example if you have a big text and
you say which is a probability that I
have this sentence I do not like
chocolate and then you can decompose it
based on the Markov chain approximation
and it's just like which is the
probability that I observe do after I
given I times the probability that you'd
observe not given do and so on so is it
right I hope so
okay to give an example the weather so
suppose we have two states for the
weather in Amsterdam
see there's sunny it's either rainy to
the cloudy then based on a sort of
observation you kind of build some
frequency and you measure some like how
the weather changes and then what you
can calculate is given that today it's
sunny which is the probability that
tomorrow is going to be again Sonny
if you live in Amsterdam zero okay I'm
joking it's just like always like to
complain about the weather in Amsterdam
but okay let you get the point like is
the probability that if it's cloudy
which is the probability tomorrow is
going to rain and of course it's high
probability that's going to rain it is
going to be sunny then you built the
probability matrix and in this matrix
you have given the present state which
is the probability of the water in
another state and then you have all this
number put up together if we take three
features like three changes on the loan
calculator and then we said we have
three ways of encoding the states that
makes three times three empty
twenty-seven possible combination so
either I change everything either I
change one either I change too and then
I leave one unchanged like all of this
it's 27 different
States and then the goal is to calculate
this 27 by 27 probability matrix and
once you have this probability matrix
you basically done you have all your
works completed and then you can use
this to calculate all your probabilities
for your population and assign that to
the good behavior and to the bad
behavior
try to distinguish them okay I like to
show this kind of a sunflower
because when you start with everything
that has changed you have 27 possibility
possibilities and you can can be any of
those and taking the example I was
showing before if you have a person
number one here which has a sequence 1 5
10 5 then the probability of this
sequence for this particular person is
decomposed based on the rule I was just
explaining before and you do that for
every person on your population and then
what you end up is like something like
that
when you have the frequencies and then
you use that for calculating the
probabilities and that is basically
building the mark of features ok now
it's time to go and see this how do we
actually do this exactly ok ok so I have
prepared for for this talk a demo
notebook here is we are going to import
all the features apart from the standard
libraries that we use for modeling I'm
going also to use function which is
helping us to encode the states and also
a class called big remodel which is
going actually to make all the
calculations under the hood for us and
then we will see the features to start
we need a data set and I think you
understand I cannot show here a bank
data but I can I can simulate data and
for that I used lsdm to simulate the
sequential data set so I'm creating
10,000 entries I'm creating thousand
sequences
and I'm creating three features of
course you are we are going to drop
masks for just in this case and then
encode the stays and here you have how
the data looks like so you have a
sequence you have a class which I have
assigned feature 1 V 0 V 1 V 3 and then
you see that for each of those features
you have the encoded States and the
changes the the person has made actually
not the person is simulated at I said
but ok and then you see the second you
if you want to see this for the first
class then here it is shown here as an
example and if you want to see it for
class one then it's also shown here in
the other example how it looks like so
at this point we are ready to calculate
the mark of features and then we are
ready to call the class background which
I wrote to calculate and then you just
do the fit it's based it's motivated by
scikit-learn so I kind of follow they're
always the the fit method and and stuff
like that because I think it's very
friend friendly to be used by everyone
and now after we have performed the fit
we want to see what is actually
happening so here it is in the print
function you have first data set
state and frequency you see that this
state 0 has a frequency which is
thousand hundred forty three and instead
in the second data set the state zero
has a like much less frequency so that
is to say that the two classes cells
different and the frequency of sequences
is different of course now of course
it's also interesting to see and to
visualize and it's also a good practice
to have these plots you'd like to see
okay I want to see which is the most
frequent effete B state so which is the
most change that happens there and for
that there are the the for the two
different data sets which are different
of course you plot the most frequent B
States in the first case you see that a
change from 26 to Z
it's much more frequent than other
states and if you look the first
population compared to the second one
you see the difference because the first
one it's 26 zero and the second one it's
20 20
so if you like to change of course this
is possible and you just type 10 here
and you want to see the let's say the
most and frequent and there you go if
you want 20 you just put 20 there and
you have all your plots you like now
let's move to the probability matrix
I suppose you're curious to see how does
it look yeah it looks like that for a
model the first model we have built here
I put like the option of log or true or
false
sometimes when you work with
probabilities they are very small so you
might prefer to go to the log space
instead of non log so this is how the
first population looked like this is the
probability matrix for the second
population and you see something is
going on there because you have these
two lines here which actually show that
something is going on and what is that
is that an anomaly can I actually detect
that what does it mean so at this point
we think that we can distinct two
classes and we are ready to build the
mark of features which are shown here so
these are only few features that you can
build then up to your case up to
whatever you want to do you can add more
and create more features but you can
take the the mean of the sequences you
can take the minimum of the sequences
then you can normalize then if you want
to go to the log space you just go to
the log space and in this case it's just
the example is shown here so it's the
Mark of sequence probe median or the
mean and other features like that
after you create features you also want
to know are they powerful are they can
we actually separate them and let's see
in that case so you want to see and for
that I have created as a function
predict proba and that is going to give
us
these two features how distinguishable
are them and here is the plot and you
can see and for the ones who are
familiar with modeling when you put this
in a in a machine learning model
definitely this feature is powerful
definitely this feature is going to be
predictive on your model and this way
you are going to be able to separate the
two classes a side note I think we are
all maybe not all but we know that
missing values sometimes can be tricky
to handle and it's always based on the
case you are working on important to
treat them properly so in this case I
don't use one sequence lengths I drop
them from a model but then there are
some ways to to treat because you have
two populations ice one population when
you make the training than one
population when you are actually testing
what you have an unseen state which
happening in the second population which
you haven't seen in the first one and
then you have to come up with some I
depending on your problem of course
coming up with some ideas how to treat
them okay
actually I have lost track of the time I
don't know when I started anymore but
maybe I am over time or too early okay
well maybe I'll get more questions
because I think I was running I was
running fast okay
to conclude Markov chain approximation
it's still a good approach for anomaly
detection and the positive sides it's
like you can understand and will explain
what are these features doing it is
productive when you have a web collected
data and that that's what I showed here
and you can perform behavioral stay
Studies on this kind of data and try to
have in your model predictive features
and these features together with other
features which I can
not share this details here are used as
a as a model we have in production and
it's very complex then I think I arrived
to the end thank you for your attention
[Applause]